estes leilões são alunos do curso
vocacional da escola secundária da
portela um percurso muito atribulado em
termos claros estes alunos a maioria
deus acumula três ou mais retenções
estão no fim da uem esta é a última
oportunidade de concluir o 3º ciclo
ou então a alternativa da na escola um
deus dos calções cor laranja
lucas tinha entrado na escola ser diz
uma coisa que deixou pensar e que é
difícil de esquecer
apontando uma sala disse
nessa direção pois é que passava mais
tempo passava na minha sala
estes alunos não são nem melhor nem pior
são diferentes e com estes alunos era
preciso fazer diferente constituir uma
equipe pedagógica do professor com uma
particularidade todos queriam fazer
diferentes e todos estavam lá pura opção
e civil se trabalhar com estes alunos
com projetos interdisciplinares
usando tecnologia project bandolim esses
projetos interdisciplinares visavam
motivar os alunos ao mesmo tempo que
estimulavam a sua criatividade ao mesmo
tempo fomentar o trabalho com o objetivo
de ensiná los a seguir um percurso em
frente à equipa fez hoje ajudou e os
robôs entraram na sala de aula mas
entraram e trouxeram com eles o que é
uma nova maneira de aprender o desafio
de construir robôs para resolver
problemas do dia a dia
a maioria não sabe programado usou uma
linguagem visual com precisa com que o
gonçalves falou há pouco
ora bem e trabalhar
ao longo do tempo foram fazendo os seus
projetos até que chegou o dia em que
viram reconhecido o seu trabalho em 16
equipes no evento e após conquistarem
quatro provas a qualidade do seu
trabalho vai altíssimo final eles eram
diferentes fizeram um trabalho de frente
trabalharam esforçaram se estudaram
trabalharam cuba dura tive mente e
tiveram aqui um dia que apresentar um
projeto científico é um júri que inclui
professores universitários tiveram uma
entrevista para avaliar um espírito de
equipa e os valores da mesma equipa na
prova de engenharia robótica tiveram que
dizer como construíram o vovô como
programaram e foi esse robô 10 na pista
e teve que prestar a prova e tentar
pontuar o máximo possível
estamos diferentes apoiados por uma
equipa do professor empenhado em fazer
diferente e concurso robôs brilhou mas
não foi só o wii
um dos projetos que fizeram representou
a escola neste caso o agrupamento no
evento concurso ciência na escola
estamos a falar concurso ciência na
escola são alunos de diferentes e tem um
percurso alternativo
estes alunos ao longo do ano letivo não
se limitarão está na sala da aula e
fazer o normal
partilharam com os colegas tudo aquilo
que aprenderam em um workshop na escola
no dia do grupamento entenderam essa
partilha outras escolas onde namisa
workshop vários colegas oficialmente a
colegas do curso vocacional dessas
escolas
lucas e hugo conseguiram fazer uma
pequena aplicação para telemóvel que é
um portal da escola e que representou o
agrupamento no evento final do projeto
apis for good que decorreu na escola com
esta turma
e quem diria
engraçado quem diria que seriam os
alunos do vocacional
agora as pessoas dizem ok me questão
tecnológica informática noções básicas
de robótica não é
ora bem diferente muito dos dias
diferentes motivaram para o acesso e
promoveram um percurso circular novo
para estes alunos por isso eu posso
dizer
o robô ajuda mas como estes alunos da
escola é pra neste país
muitos alunos que precisavam de um roubo
qualquer para ajudar
cabe nos a nós contribuir para isso
obrigado